le savent où je nous sommes en plein
travail de répétition de vera au théâtre
d'hérouville avec karin viard l'actrice
principale et marcial di fonzo bo le
metteur en scène
de quoi parle cette pièce qui verra
alors verra donc c'est l'histoire d'une
d'une agence d'une agent de comédien
c'est peut-être et les canoteurs tchèque
doc est créé la pièce et par le prisme
de la vie de vera cette femme donc qui
dirige l'agencé
il a apporté la société d'aujourd'hui on
sait que le milieu artistique toujours
sauvage puisqu'il est question nos coûts
du du commerce toujours c'est une
industrie est donc le mot industrie à
côté de 2,2 du choix deux des comédiens
des humains peut faire une addition
assez sanglante
maintenant tu peux en parler maintenant
la télévision rentrer dans vos foyers
maintenant il n'y a plus de sujet tabou
le monde
koster est un principe des missions du
bâti comme ça qui bâtit des jdc la
troisième collaboration avec martial
qu'est ce qu'il a de différent des
autres metteurs en scène pourquoi lui
travailler avec martial c'est c est dans
la jubilation c'est maintenant je sais
c'est être très exactement là où moi je
je lutte pour être toujours c'est à dire
être dans le plaisir n'être pas dans le
devoir pas dans la culpabilité être dans
le plaisir immédiat archaïques comme ça
on est des enfants dans les spectacles
de partial ya toujours plusieurs
personnages il ya des perruques on se
griment se déguise les femmes sondées
sur femmes c'est voilà les hommes sont
déguisés en femme j'ai pas il ya quelque
chose comme ça de tellement jubilatoire
que j'ai l'impression que je pourrais
plus travailler avec quelqu'un d'autre
aujourd'hui ça me manquerait cependant
le désir établi
eu plus de mouvements je n'aime pas le
de la fin d'accord ok bon jour
formidable que vous soyez là excusez moi
de lotus eu il ya peu de café non merci
ce qui est génial dans la pièce c'est
que autour du rôle de vera il y à une
vingtaine une trentaine de personnages
donc ça c'est encore du pain bénit comme
on dit pour les acteurs et moi-même juge
jaune et denham nogueira joue avec nos
pierre mallet jure avec nour de le faut
des sous ça et aussi louve à l'anti ni
donc à cinq autres on arrive à faire une
vingtaine trentaine de rôles et sesat
déplace aussi complètement la
théâtralité
après j'attends de la manière laisse la
place pour qu'on attendait oui tu peux
m'habiller dans dix minutes je sors de
la baignoire et quand on parle du
théâtre c'est toujours un peu je veux
dire les gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude
d'aller au théâtre peuvent toujours se
dire que c'est pas pour la celle inverse
moi je trouve que c'est très
contemporain très drôle très accessible
c'est rose c'est du spectacle c'est ça
que j'aime bien aussi avec martial et je
trouve que voilà pour les gens n'ont pas
l'habitude d'aller au théâtre c'est pas
bourgeois c'est vachement bien pour ça
que dire de plus sinon de venir entre le
25 et le 29 avril au théâtre
d'hérouville merci infiniment cabinet
merci merci beaucoup
et maintenant retrouvons sabine daniel
pour le début du festival normandie
impressionniste au musée des beaux-arts
de caen avec un peintre norvégien pied
frixtalon fritz tholot est un peintre
d'origine norvégienne
non mais il est européen il a beaucoup
voyagé je dirais même que c'est un
artiste voyageur un nomade un européen
citoyen du monde
m
contrairement aux impressionnistes qui
paye devant la nature fruit de cette
europe 1 dans la nature c'est une des
différences avec claude monet
par exemple une autre différence c'est
que lui ne s'intéresse pas à la
sensation du papilles hautement à cette
touche fragmenté c'est un printemps
plutôt réaliste il veut donner
l'illusion du volume et de la profondeur
de l'eau monnaie sous son lit lui c'est
effectivement globaux vivante l'eau
mouvante qui l'intéressent plus
particulièrement il est aussi également
influencé par les estampes japonaises
d'où cet horizon extrêmement courts et
qui donne l'impression au spectateur de
surplomber finalement la vue qu'il nous
offre
nous sommes immergés dans la nature
c'est un art de l'immersion c'est un
artiste d'une acuité incroyable et quasi
quasi et écologistes c'est parce qu'ils
étaient norvégien oui absolument
ils ont les scandinaves ont une
sensibilité particulière vivre en
harmonie et pas contre la nature être en
fusion
quelles que soient les saisons et quel
que soit le leur aussi triste lot à pain
de l'aube au crépuscule et représenter
toutes les saisons c'est il aimait la
nature
il était un bohème et il a fait de la
nature un cadre de vie
et
n'oubliez pas de passer par bayeux au
musée d'art et d'histoire il s'agira de
parler de caillebotte et de son intimité
et puis à granville au musée anacréon
ces belles de nuit les femmes sur une
toile et à travers leurs objets et
demain sur france 3 normandie
la voie est libre sera consacré à ce
festival normandie impressionniste
ce à partir de 11h30 bon week end